qué
a
[Música]
ah
oro petróleo esmeraldas colombia tiene
todo tipo de recursos naturales por lo
que la minería y el extractivismo se
convierten en una actividad económica
pero también en un peligro para los
defensores de la tierra y especialmente
para las mujeres así lo muestra un
informe de derecho ambiente y recursos
naturales y la fundación para el debido
proceso en colombia se calcula que en
los últimos siete años ha habido más de
80 líderes as asesinadas con un 91 por
ciento de impunidad en estos casos son
varios ejemplos este 2020
juana maría perea plata una activista
hispana colombiana fue asesinada el 28
de octubre por hombres del
autodenominado clan del golfo la
lideresa se oponía a la construcción del
puerto de tribugá en el pacífico
colombiano o también a principios de
octubre analucía bisbicus de los
indígenas awá fue asesinada por un grupo
armado en nariño una zona con grandes
conflictos por la tierra desde la red
latinoamericana de mujeres defensoras
denuncian que el extractivismo afecta al
cuerpo de las mujeres al ser el primer
espacio de conquista pero al mismo
tiempo también reivindican el cuerpo
como un escenario de defensa propia y
del territorio
[Música]
en perú los proyectos extractivistas han
significado para las mujeres indígenas
rurales y defensoras medioambientales un
permanente riesgo de violencia en el
cual se denuncian es ejercido por
integrantes de las empresas que se
posesión dentro de sus territorios
ancestrales un estudio elaborado por las
organizaciones ambientales revela que
entre los años 2013 y 2017 los
conflictos sociales ocasionaron la
muerte de diez peruanas en paralelo en
el 2017 se registraron 102 indígenas
criminalizadas por protestar en la
defensa de sus comunidades ante la
instalación de los proyectos mineros
petroleros gasíferos a sí mismos
diversos activistas denuncian que la
violencia que sufren las mujeres
peruanas se desprende en actos de
racismo criminalización violencia física
así como violencia sexual se
responsabiliza por las agresiones a
algunos agentes del orden y trabajadores
foráneos de las industrias extractivas
algunos colectivos indígenas también
señalan que la crisis sanitaria por el
kobe 19 no ha detenido a la explotación
de los recursos naturales por parte de
las empresas por el contrario la
cuarentena habría facilitado más abusos
[Música]
según un estudio de géneros de
industrias extractivas en américa
latina' honduras es uno de los países en
donde las mujeres corren mayor riesgo
que los hombres en cuanto a la defensa
de el ambiente esta opinión coincide con
varios organismos internacionales
quienes consideran que este país
centroamericano es uno de los más
peligrosos del mundo para los defensores
de los derechos humanos y de la tierra
el caso más conocido es el de la líder
ambientalista berta cáceres quien fue
asesinada la madrugada del 2 de marzo
del 2016 en su hogar
bertha cáceres mundialmente conocida por
su defensa del ambiente y de las
comunidades indígenas se oponía a la
construcción de varias empresas
hidroeléctricas a orillas del río walk
al que por considerarse este proyecto de
gran impacto para el ambiente e incluso
ponía en peligro a las etnias que ahí
residen por el asesinato de cáceres se
encuentra preso el presidente de la
empresa de esa encargada de la
construcción de estos proyectos también
hace unos meses fue asesinada en el
sector sur del país otra
líder campesina tiene junto a varios
compañeros estaban defendiendo su
territorio en ese sector del país
[Música]